c'est officiellement un jour de fête à
encore et voici à quoi ressemble à peu
près tous les coins de rues du
centre-ville depuis dimanche le terrain
de guerre où les lignes de front ne ce
compte là où les manifestations se
déplacent les policiers à temps et en
heure gaz lacrymogènes balles de
caoutchouc poivre de cayenne
ces protestataires de première ligne les
frites niners comme on les appelle ici
sont elles fatiguent
nous allons humilie le régime chinois
pour la grande fête nationale et nous
allons défendre nos droits
cinq cents mètres plus loin où la
manifestation semble beaucoup plus calme
la panique s'installe rapidement
attention le gaz qui ces jeunes femmes
la foule se disperse l'idée parce qu'ils
observent duo des pompiers temps ce qui
est devenu le nouveau normal les
affrontements de plus en plus violent et
surtout epr est visé ces jeunes
préparent la réplique y relancer leurs
projectiles en pierres sur les bureaux
du gouvernement central dans quand la
chef car il à hama qui on reproche
d'être le pantin de la chine aura été
jusqu'ici incapable de contenir la rage
de cette nouvelle génération et ses
images de chaos dont exactement ce que
pékin redoutait pour le jour de son
grand 70e
c'est une insulte majeure ces
manifestations hong kong appartient à la
chine cet homme qui n'en peut plus de la
casse
si le 1er octobre était perçu comme une
date clé pour mettre fin à la dissidence
les autorités aujourd'hui se prépare
plutôt à des tensions records
on est à quelques heures seulement les
grandes manifestations interdites mais
déjà regardé on est devant un magasin
qui vend l'équipement de protection
comme des casques pour les manifestants
et la police montent la garde et
inspecte les allées et les venues de
tous ceux qui se procurent du matériel
de protection
la police prévient d'ailleurs que les
célébrations du 70e anniversaire de la
chine communiste sont assombries qu'elle
ne peut rien garantir que la journée
s'annonce des plus dangereuses depuis le
début du mouvement
tamare altérer ce que radio-canada pas